how's it going Braz - Pierre welcome to
another episode of some Bank souls - the
[ __ ] I wait two weeks for a seven-minute
video that'll teach title [ __ ] hey
we barely pulled through the last
episodes I really don't see us doing
that well this one so you bros told me
you can use this crossbow or to actually
kill the boss in like one hit or
whatever yeah just work I really
appreciate you bros give me tips how
about next time you give them before the
fight
that'd be great thank you oh now I can
finally make some omelet [ __ ] yeah hey I
wasn't gonna eat eggs I was just gonna
wear them as hats like Jesus we would
fly for a base wait a goddamn jet like a
monkey as [ __ ] now we're waiting it's
lip I always am surprised beautiful oh
god you're ugly Justin Bieber what are
you doing here alright what goes in here
yoohoo and Saturday what harm
oh come on I thought maybe one or two
not the god damn army what if I kill
them one by one genius
can you try and be a little less ugly
that'd be great
I actually think that's impossible I'm
gonna have to kill you I'm sorry the
ugliness is too strong for this one what
is in here no all right
it's hopefully not a boss
best phosphide ever so good best boss
fight down bar best boss fight down that
is so [ __ ] dark souls so apparently
I'm playing the champion covenant which
makes them do like double damage or
something I don't know it makes a game
harder at least that's all I know I
don't know how to get rid of it
I guess I'm stock I'd [ __ ] [ __ ] a
maka [ __ ] up phone alright let's go in
here
Thank You Dark Souls Thank You snow all
right second try baby don't hit me
yeah now I slap you I flat for you I fly
for you oh god yeah I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry hey that doesn't mean you can slap
back
oh yeah bet you're really fun at parties
aren't you I miss me [ __ ] 5 u 5u u
can't touch this you can't touch this
you can't
[Music]
where the hell did he go where the photo
should come on [ __ ] sake I don't
understand why you don't like my slaps
most people like them I promise just
give it a go here
there you go haha alright let me jump
down see how that goes
[ __ ] great unicorn time [ __ ] come on
Galicia
and Rococo recalc out break out out but
how cow we made at last Rococo it looks
like I have to fight bull for them at
the same time and please let me help
Li's let me help leave let me help
I'm a unicorn I've had to chase you with
my own eyes
Trumbo yeah that's right I said it
Trumbo but some of these a bit sensitive
god damn I look good chicken and gather
for [ __ ] sake don't touch me I'm famous
I'm famous how many times I have to say
here don't touch me I'm payment all
right one down two to go baby
I know we can't do this press but let's
pretend that we came just for a minute
let's go down I guess [ __ ] hate you I
hope you get a hemorrhoid in your tent
that is nasty I don't know why I came up
with that I'm sorry I can't even [ __ ]
kill the first one I can't even [ __ ]
kill the first one
you haven't played Dark Souls you don't
get it okay
I think we're a little under level but
I'm sure Rick I'll go back if that's
your real name bet you some weird
stripper name or some [ __ ] like don't
touch me
you touch me I will talk I don't know
they spin the rope if you throw the
spinner oh I will have to initiate kung
fu' there's no kung fu in Dark Souls
which is a damn shame I will get you
bring Coco clap you that's right one
slap at a time Rococo I got my eye on
you [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god I'm alive I'm alive I'm alive and
wonder if I can make the like the
pillars no no no no
that one hurt so much I can't explain
how it physically works with Dark Souls
but somehow my anus alright alright
don't do the spinner Oh cuz imma have to
slap you and double five-year Oh God
double spin there I should have seen it
coming well did you see this flap coming
no you're in Oh God
triple spin or what is the distal end
imma have to slap you both down for
disrespecting me oh god Rococo Rococo
Rococo we talked about this so many
[ __ ] times mate
these guys go to my [ __ ] help oh oh
I think I pooped a little and guys stop
smelling my butt oh come on it's not
real poop Oh double spin the rift that
means I can proper double flapper
should I finish it to the video chip
Oh
[Applause]
Rococo I'm sorry but you gotta go mad Oh
don't [ __ ] this up yeah I'm gonna heal
how to give a shake
and we do everybody's job
[Music]
I don't know if I'll ever play this
better [ __ ] leave a like you love but
I mean I love you rose stay awesome
it's the sky girl Ruth today you love
your brother